[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Well, now, we're going
to turn to ethics,
which is something
that undergirds
all of these discussions.
And to introduce our speaker,
we have Danielle Allen
who is the Director of the
Safra Center for Ethics
here at Harvard University
and a professor here
in the Departments of
Government and at the Graduate
School of Education.
Professor Allen is a political
theorist, author of many books
that you can see
in your program,
and co-editor of the
award-winning Education,
Justice, and Democracy.
She's also been a chair of
several prestigious boards,
including the Mellon Foundation
and the Pulitzer Prize
Committee.
She is a member of
the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences and the
American Philosophical Society.
So it's a real pleasure
to welcome Danielle Allen.
[APPLAUSE]
-Well, we are all here
to hear from Mr. Caplan,
so I won't spend long
on my introduction--
only call your attention to some
of his important biographical
details.
It matters a lot to me that he
majored in philosophy, which
I take to be an excellent
starting point for tackling all
of the hardest
questions-- many of which
emerged already in
the first two panels
that we've heard this morning.
And I'm very much
looking forward
to hearing Arthur
Caplan direct us
to what he considers the
foremost ethical problems
involving DNA.
He is currently the Drs.
William F. and Virginia
Connolly Mitty Professor
and head of the Division
of Medical Ethics at NYU
University.
After having also been
at Penn for many years,
he has published many books.
You'll also know him
from his writings
for bioethics on NBC.com
and WebMD Medscape.
He is currently involved in
several important projects--
too many to go
through all together--
but he asked me to call out
his work for the World Health
Organization on ethical
issues related to Ebola
and also his work on an
experimental advisory committee
at the moment with
Johnson & Johnson
where the question
is how to allocate
unapproved medications.
So it's with great
pleasure and interest
I welcome Arthur Caplan.
[APPLAUSE]
-Well, it has been said that,
to do the ethics of genomics,
you do need a lot of
training because you
have to learn to say no in a
variety of different languages.
But this will not be a talk
about saying no or saying
what objections or
problems there are.
In fact, it may not be
a talk about anything
at all because I
don't see my clicker.
Is that up here?
Did that walk?
Oh, here it is.
Got it.
So let me summarize
where we're going to go.
I've been interested
in genetics,
and it's followed into
the practice of medicine
for many, many years.
In fact, way, way long ago,
I believe in the 16th century
when I was working as a
post-doc at The Hastings
Center, a thinktank-- one
of the original locations
to think about ethics,
medicine, and science.
We were all very excited
when we got a paper published
in The New England
Journal on ethical issues
around genetic screening
for sickle cell disease,
and it turned out
to be very important
that we wrote that paper.
They were at least
two states that
had required sickle cell
testing and prohibited children
from coming to school if they
were positive for sickle cell.
So I wouldn't say we
were way on the cutting
edge of societal
understanding of genetics.
And we basically tried
to argue at that time
that it was very important to
have good counseling if you
were going to do mass
genetic screening.
The other area that was of
keen interest at the time
was what to do about
prenatal testing
in terms of genetic analysis.
And some of you will know that
the field of genetic counseling
began right after World War II.
It started with
chromosomal analysis,
and the disease that really
caught peoples' attention
was Down syndrome because you
could accurately diagnose it.
And those programs began to
flourish right after the war
and basically use this new
knowledge of chromosome testing
to offer it to women, but
the only way to get DNA
was to take it by needle from
fluid in the amniotic sac
surrounding the fetus.
That's risky.
It can cause an abortion
to happen if you manipulate
the fetus or the fluid.
You can introduce
infection, and there are
a variety of other problems.
And so ultimately, this first
type of testing prenatally
was confined to
women at older ages--
particularly over 35--
because they were considered
to have the greatest risk
of having a child with Down
syndrome because the increasing
incidence of the disease
associated with older age.
Subsequently, it turned
out, about 30 years later,
we found out that there was also
a little bit of an association
with older men.
But as was pointed out
earlier, their contribution
to reproduction's never been
fully appreciated anyway,
so nobody really chased that
very hard to begin with.
Well, I'm going to
tell you a couple
of little interesting
facts about DNA testing.
One interesting fact
was genetic counseling
was firmly and strongly
and unabashedly neutral.
When it first began,
genetic counselors
almost swore an oath.
We will never direct,
influence, shape
the opinion of our patient
or our counselee in any way,
shape, or form.
We're just here to
give information.
For those of you very old, it
was a Jack Webb philosophy--
just the facts.
-[CHUCKLING]
-That's it.
We don't tell you what to do.
We don't tell you what you
ought to do with these results.
We just give you information.
Part of the reason they
took this neutral stance
was that they were just
coming out of World War II.
They were just coming out of
an era of Nazi race hygiene.
an era of forced sterilization
of people on racial grounds.
They were coming out of
an era of, if you will,
coerced eugenics.
They wanted nothing to do
with that period of history,
and they partly drew
the line and said,
"We don't counsel people
about what to do,"
because they didn't want
any association with, let's
call it, Nazi race hygiene.
Secondly, they wound up
being neutral in their way
because they knew that that
was the right way to counsel
because they had
all studied Freud.
The dominant way to
counsel at the time
was to have the
patient talk a lot
and the counselor not respond
very often at all, if at all.
I mean, you listen
to Woody Allen.
He says his the
analyst talked to him
only when soliciting the bill.
-[CHUCKLING]
-But there was a notion that
you would reach objectivity
with your patient if you didn't
try to impose your values.
You let them talk.
And so that was very
much in the air.
So a combination of factors led
the original genetic counselors
to really take a
position that's neutral.
Now, some things have changed.
What has changed
since that time is we
do a lot more genetic testing.
And in particular,
we're starting
to do more tests that
involve neurological testing.
So genetic testing
is being done for
various neurological conditions
in fetuses, newborns, children,
and adults.
Fragile X is one that
you will all know,
but there are many where people
try to examine something having
to do with cognitive abilities.
There are some early stage
tests that are going on with
Alzheimer's.
And much as we heard in
the previous talk, too,
some of the testing is being
offered, what I would say,
prematurely.
It's not really verified.
The science isn't great.
But for some of
the tests, they're
excellent because partly we're
not talking gene sequences.
We're talking broken
or missing chromosomes.
So these are a bit
easier to detect.
So brain and behavior
are especially
provocative in American society.
When we start talking about
testing for those things,
we're in a
highly-competitive society.
Many people will seek
any means possible to get
an edge with respect
to mental performance.
And especially, they
fear mental deficiency.
But what I mean is for getting
an edge on mental performance,
they will, in fact, carefully
select their neighborhood
so they can put their kid
in the right nursery school
so it's a guarantee that they
can enroll here something.
Right?
I mean, people go crazy
to try and give their kids
any sort of an advantage.
And it's not confined
to the United States.
You can see it in Singapore.
You can see it in
many other societies.
So what I'm going to talk about
for the rest of these remarks
is Down syndrome.
And it's the early forerunner
test, as I told you,
but what has been changing
about Down Syndrome?
Well, back in the day, when
this testing first begin,
there were plenty of kids
around in cities, in towns,
and out in the community
who had Down syndrome.
In fact, I've been to
Ireland a couple of times
myself recently.
And one of the things
I quickly noticed
is there are more
children on the streets
and around who
have Down syndrome,
but they're not here anymore.
What's happened
with Down syndrome
is it's something, as you can
see from these survey results,
that many people have
negative attitudes about now.
They don't think
they would want to go
to school with kids with Down.
They think they
will be slowed down
if they have to have a
Down's kid in the classroom,
and there are a lot of
attitudes about Down
that just aren't often
discussed in polite company
basically because it's a
cognitive defect that people
worry about.
I'm going to skip this just
in the interest of time.
This is a really
interesting case,
but ask me about it later.
Other neurological tests that
are coming down the road.
Not here yet.
This is the future
aspect of DNA.
We're going to be looking at
propensity to become addicted
to nicotine, cocaine, heroin.
These are all marker-type
things with neural transmission
factors that we're going
to be able to test for.
Probably find certain
genetic characteristics that
could be dubbed "antisocial."
This could make you
a criminal or a CEO.
-[LAUGHING]
-Or maybe those are
hard to distinguish.
We'll leave that for
the business school.
Probably got some genetic
disposition to homosexuality
that will be detectable.
Risk for autism, absolutely.
Response to various
types of medications
for your schizophrenia,
your depression,
your bipolar
disease, absolutely.
So this whole area
brain and behavior
is one that is going to be
upon us very, very fast.
The Down syndrome experience
I'm about to describe to you
is very predictive for some
of the ethical challenges that
are in store.
What's wrong with
getting your fetus tested
or your kid tested?
Well, parents can overreact.
They can keep their
addicted risk child isolated
in a kind of
super-helicopter environment,
not let them get near
anything that might give them
a pleasurable experience.
-[CHUCKLING]
-Just seeing if you're there.
-You could keep your
antisocial risk child
under close surveillance,
any kind of behavior that
was indicative
that they might be
going in the wrong direction,
try to deprogram them
if they thought
homosexuality might emerge.
So you could get a
lot of bad parenting
if you were worried about
hypercompetitive parents who
really care about the brains
of their kids-- less the bodies
of their kids-- and you could
see them ending pregnancies
just on these risk
factor kinds of things.
I have not surveyed, but we're
doing a survey now of attitudes
about when parents might
end a pregnancy for any
of those reasons on that list--
homosexuality, autism, and so
on.
So Down, just to remind
you, is the most common
chromosomal condition.
There are a lot of people
with Down syndrome.
It has cognitive developmental
delays associated with it,
but the effect is usually mild
to moderate and the individuals
who have Down's possess
many strengths and talents.
That sounds pretty good.
That's a description of
Down from the Down Syndrome
Association.
This is the description
from the CDC.
People with Down
syndrome usually
have an IQ in the mildly
to moderately low range.
And then they list a variety of
common health problems, which
isn't on the Down
syndrome page, including
hearing loss and sleep apnea and
ear infections and eye diseases
and a lot of heart
defects, a lot
of health problems associated
with the chromosomal anomaly--
not described on the
Down's Association page,
described on the CDC page.
I just pulled one
other one out for you.
It's not as clear,
but it basically
is the Mayo page online.
And it says kids with Down have
a variety of complications.
They lead with heart
defects, talk about leukemia.
There's nothing there
about mild to moderate,
and there's nothing there
about a lot of potential.
You can see Down's
in a lot of ways.
And if you don't think values
play a huge role in how
we understand what's
a testable condition
or something worthy
of being tested for,
you're not paying attention.
But interesting enough,
how do you counsel?
There's three different sources
I gave you about Down right
online.
Do you talk to the parents of
kids with Down's and with Down
Association?
Do you talk to the CDC?
Do you talk to a medical
site, like the Mayo Clinic?
You're going to get
three different stories.
Here's a story from a parent
named Tara McCallan, who's
Canadian, but there are
plenty of these stories
from all around the world.
She had a hard time
accepting her Down's kid.
She's thought a lot about
ending the pregnancy,
but she had the baby.
Today, she celebrates
her differences.
She basically says-- I
didn't put it up there.
But that picture that
you're seeing there is up
on a billboard in Toronto,
and it's basically saying I
celebrate Down's.
We should all
celebrate Down's kids.
They really make a
contribution to our lives,
to their siblings' lives,
to the lives of families.
There has been a
movement, in other words,
to make Down's more mainstream.
And literally, you can see it.
I'm sure many of you
have seen the Down's kid
who's in the beauty pageant,
the Down's child who's
now a fashion model.
There's a Down's child or
two who are cheerleaders,
and many, many other
activities intended
to say, look, Down's
kids might be different,
but they're certainly
not some kind of pariah.
And I'm hinting at the fact that
they're certainly not something
that you would abort.
So this is the American
College of Obstetrics
and Gynecologists's
recommendation about getting
screened if you're a mom.
And you'll notice
something-- they
think that, in terms of testing
for Down-- when the testing is
very, very good, they have
both a chemical test to see
if protein is present
in the amniotic fluid.
And you can also do ultrasound
testing to see the shape
of body parts of the fetus,
which indicate Down's.
You can do this, as I
said, by amniocentesis.
You can do it by chorionic
villus sampling, which
is taking a piece of the tissue
from the lining of the cervix.
Things get in there as well
that you can test for, cells.
And there's actually cord
analysis that can be done,
although that's even
dangerous to do, too.
So there's a lot of
ways to test for Down's.
I'm not going to
talk about them,
but you could also
test the embryos
and not use ones that are
Down that you've identified
and only select embryos
at an IVF center.
You might go there
even if you weren't
infertile to test your
embryos if you were trying
to avoid a kid with Down.
This is what's coming.
And this is the
future, and this is
why bioethicists will have
employment for some time
to come.
Cell-free DNA analysis.
So it turns out that
you can pull DNA
from the fetus out of
the circulating blood
of the mom at about 10 weeks.
So you don't have
to do amniocentesis
and you don't have to
do chorionic villus
and you don't have to go through
all the rigmarole of getting
a test, growing out the cells,
and finding out-- perhaps
at 18, 19, or 20 weeks--
whether Down's is present
in your fetus.
You can do it all at 10 weeks.
Earlier for many people
morally would be better.
Harder to end a pregnancy
later and more risky.
It can indicate--
you can do that test
and say, well, I want to do the
amniocentesis as a follow-up.
But the more accurate
cell-free DNA testing
gets, the less likely
that's going to be.
Right now, cell-free DNA
testing is recommended for women
at higher risk-- meaning
older or because they've
had another test and it's
becoming confirmatory.
But the honest truth
is this-- cell-free DNA
testing, within the next
three to four years,
is going to be
routine in obstetrics
for every single
woman who's pregnant.
It's cheap to do.
It's part of blood analysis.
You're just going to run it.
I doubt there will be
a separate consent.
It will just get done as part of
the battery of things that get
done when you come in pregnant.
Interesting enough, you're
going to come in and get
that testing done
in a setting where
there's no genetic counselor.
You're going to have
an obstetrician.
Are obstetricians non-directive?
Oh, yeah.
-[LAUGHING]
-They say things like,
"You look like you're
getting a little diabetic.
You're going to lose weight,
get in bed, and not move."
-[LAUGHING]
-It's pretty directive.
Most physicians are directive.
They don't say
things like, "Gee.
Your blood pressure's
220 over 140.
Do what you want."
-[LAUGHING]
-Right?
So we then
hospitalize you, bring
you-- put you on medicine, and
then we're going to intervene.
Let me summarize it this way.
Every single woman
who gets pregnant
is going to have
cell-free DNA testing.
We have a window
into the fetus that's
emerging that will
go past Down syndrome
but includes Down syndrome.
And counseling is going
to be done by a doctor,
not by counselor.
There aren't enough counselors
around in the United States
to do genetic counseling.
There are probably
12,000 of them total
in the whole country.
This counseling is
going to get done
by people who don't have
the tradition of neutrality
or non-directiveness
that I was talking about.
They're very
directive, and they're
going to be sending
messages to women
about what they think they
ought to do if Down is detected.
What that message
is, I'm not sure,
but I know what some
people are worrying about.
So not too long ago, I
heard about some laws
that were quietly passing
both at the federal level,
but interesting enough,
at the state level.
The Down Syndrome
information Act.
There was one in Pennsylvania
where I was at the time.
Eight states actually have it,
and Massachusetts turns out
to be one of them.
These states require
medical professionals,
when they do a test
for Down, to provide
evidence-based
information on Down along
with support contacts
and resources
to Down Association individuals.
Other states have
the bills pending.
The fact is abortion,
after a detection
of Down in the US percentage
of pregnancies that are ended,
probably somewhere
between 70 and 85%.
Down's Association
people look at that,
like the mom who had
the poster of her kid
and said this kid
contributes a lot to my life
and is a meaningful family
member-- although she's
one of the few moms to
have a Down's child.
And by the way, the rate in the
UK, abortion for Down is 90%.
Denmark is about 88%.
So this condition, when
detected, ends pregnancies.
The Down's association
is well aware of that,
and they are passing
laws that say--
when you counsel someone
who has had Down detected,
we want a message
sent that's positive.
We what you to talk about the
opportunities, the contribution
that they can make as
individuals to a family.
We don't want sort of an
antidisability message sent.
We want to see
that you are trying
to give people hope that
they should accept the Down's
child into their lives.
And there's at least one
state that has banned abortion
for Down, North Dakota.
And Ohio has a
bill pending right
before the governor today.
Now, that probably
is unconstitutional
given the way Roe
v. Wade is written,
but it doesn't much matter.
It's sending a huge
message, and I'm
going to tell you a little
bit here about the politics.
There's the Down
syndrome numbers,
which I already told about.
Just racing.
Watching the clock here.
That's what the UN Rights of
Persons with Disabilities says.
We're signatories.
Don't discriminate
against the disabled.
Respect difference.
Accept persons with
disabilities as part
of human diversity and humanity.
Respect evolving capacities
of children with disabilities.
If you have an 85%
to 90% abortion rate,
some in the Down
community and some
in the disability community
are going to say-- really?
That is nice rhetoric.
Why are you killing us?
I'm going to tell
you-- and I'm not
going to bother with
the slides anymore.
I'm just going to end on a sort
of highly provocative note.
What's the future?
The future is a lot more
ability to do prenatal testing
than we ever could because
the means to do the testing
is coming out of
the bloodstream.
The bloodstream gets
tested regularly.
It's minor.
It's easy to do.
More and more labs and
more and more locations
will have the
capability to do this.
It will be routine.
I would probably
predict that, if you
don't offer this in
three or four years,
you'll be sued for not
following standard of care
as an obstetrician.
That is, the legal
expectation will
be that you do offer free-cell
DNA testing of the fetus.
It's also the case
that we're going
to expand into many areas
that make people very
nervous-- homosexuality,
autism, problems
of antisocial behavior.
And whether you think there's
such a thing as antisociality
that can be impacted in
terms of really identifying
some genetic factors or
other personality disorders,
somebody's going to market it.
The word will go out that,
if you have this footprint,
you're at a higher risk
of having a kid who's
going to run into trouble.
Those of you who remember
the extra Y chromosome
fiasco from probably
20 years ago
where there was a criminality
gene that was highly-touted
and something to be
avoided and-- excuse me,
a criminality chromosome
and was easily detected.
There were a number of
abortions done because
of that criminal
chromosome being picked up
although the
association turned out
to be weak and fairly specious.
It's coming again, and what's
coming down the road for all
of us into the future
of genetic testing
is the ethical challenge of
the spin of the counseling.
We have a lot of rhetoric that
says we accept the disabled.
We want to integrate
the disabled.
We're ramping.
We have bathrooms--
I just went to one
out there-- for the disabled.
But the disability
community is going
to say, if there
aren't going to be
any disabled people--
at least, those
that have congenital
disabilities because you're
going to kill us all
in the womb-- then
in what sense are we
to believe that you
have a respect for disability?
And we're going
to pass laws that
make you tout to potential
parents the advantages
or the opportunities
or the enrichment
that can be brought by
adding "difference"-- not
"disability"-- into families.
And we want those messages sent.
Because if you've got
an 80% abortion rate,
then I don't care what you say.
You're not neutral.
And if all you talk about is the
risk of Down when you counsel,
that isn't neutral.
So make it neutral by
balancing, by having
much more directive counseling.
So who are the friends of
this political movement?
It's right-to-life and pro-life.
The enemies are
the more secular.
Think of them as the
Planned Parenthood proponent
crowd who respect choice and
have built their argument
around reproductive
freedom, around choice.
Pro-life basically says
we respect the disabled,
and you can see the
states passing these laws.
They're basically moving
through politically
with the support of pro-life
groups backing them up.
I'll end on this note.
That alliance is powerful.
Years ago, we had a practice
that I knew about very well.
It was one of the reasons I
got interested in bioethics.
When a child was born
with Down or spina bifida
or other congenital defects,
if the parents said,
"There are medical
complications.
Don't treat my child.
We don't want them
to live," the doctors
would put the baby in a
corner and let them die.
They wouldn't feed them,
and they would die.
This is not a secret.
It was published in The
New England Journal, Duff
and Campbell-- two major
neonatologists at Yale--
wrote it up.
John Lorber wrote it up many,
many times in British Medical
Journal and lots of
publications and defended
the practice saying parents
should have the right to choose
not to treat these infants.
Some of you will remember
that C. Everett Koop did not
make his mark initially on HIV.
He made his mark on
the "Baby Doe" laws.
Conservatives and pro-lifers
stepped in and said you cannot
kill these infants.
You should not allow them to
die from treatable conditions.
No matter what the
parents say, you
should protect disabled kids.
From that alliance was
formed a connection
between the disability community
and the pro-life community.
There is no such alliance
on the other side.
The alliance
maintains, and that's
why you're seeing these
laws moving through saying
we want to enrich the
message about Down's, we
want to cut the abortion
rate for Down's, or we're
going to ban
disability as a reason
to have an abortion-- backed
up by the pro-life side
of the argument about abortion.
That's the future.
We are on the edge, not just
of genetic breakthroughs,
but of one hell of a
battle about what you
say to somebody when you detect
Down or autism or homosexuality
or whatever the
congenital defect might be
and what freedom you have
or are going to have to act
to terminate that pregnancy.
And I don't think people
are watching it closely,
but I'm here to tell you I
think that's the future I see.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you very much.
We'll take some questions.
If you could, again, come
up to the microphone.
Say your name, and keep
your question as a question.
That would be great.
While we're waiting
here a second,
I'm struck by-- you
spoke a lot-- sorry.
You're on mic, but I'm not.
So I have to get in front of it.
It's OK.
About the implications
for abortion of diagnosis,
of these genetic-based
deficiencies,
but I'm struck by-- we have
increasingly an ability
to cure some of them.
So already, for example, we test
for a G6PD deficiency at birth.
This is a genetic
enzyme deficiency,
which, if you avoid certain
foods and medicines,
you can lead a
perfectly normal life.
If you don't know
about that, you
end up with a disability
that can be pretty profound.
We're going to be
talking this afternoon
about CRISPR technology
which will increasingly
provide the potential
for gene editing--
perhaps the cure of such things.
I don't know if you can get
rid of a whole chromosome
as in Downs but other
such potential therapies.
Would you mind saying
a word about what
you think about
therapy as opposed
to abortions that change
the ethical dilemma at all?
-So I think there
will be opportunities
to do some human
germline interventions
and potential cures.
I would expect them to be
around in about 20 years.
Looking in the human
germline is going
to turn out to be one
tricky, difficult process,
and it won't take too many
disasters of something
going wrong-- a la Jesse
Gelsinger and gene therapy
not that many years ago-- before
somebody says knock that off.
Keep doing it on
animals, and call me
when you're absolutely sure
you know what you're doing.
I've seen this enthusiasm
explosion many times.
I saw it for fetal tissue.
I saw it for gene therapy.
I saw it for embryonic
stem cells-- all of which
in recent memory
have been cured.
We can't even convince
people to eat GMO.
So why anybody
thinks you're going
to run around doing
germline human modification
without enormous
controversy is beyond me.
So that's point one.
Point two.
Even if you could do it and
do it accurately and even
if George Church comes later
and says, oh, it's wrong,
I can pinpoint everything,
and I can fix this
and [INAUDIBLE] has turned into
the giant Google of its day.
That's inside baseball
jokes for all of you.
I think that the
you're going to still
have a fight on your
hands because people
are going to say, as they do in
the Deaf movement today, germy?
Germy of what?
I'm just different.
Why are you curing me?
In fact, you proved my point.
You're a bigot.
It's sort of-- I don't
need to be cured.
I'm just different.
I'm Asperger-ish or
maybe I'm autistic
or maybe I have an
oddball personality.
Anybody seen my paintings?
-[CHUCKLING]
-You know, it's that
sort of argument.
So I think we'll be in
the middle of that even
with intervention possible.
Yeah?
-Hi.
I'm Andrew Bergman.
I'm a PhD student in the
Department of Applied Physics.
I apologize if this
is a stupid question
or at least poorly-formulated.
A lot of--
-Well, a stupid question
for a stupid talk.
Very appropriate.
-Sounds good.
A lot of your conversation
about Down Syndrome
was connected specifically
to the issue of having
abortions to prevent it.
I'm wondering-- in some
hypothetical, futuristic
scenario where you can
maybe just take a supplement
or something that is just
not connected to abortion
any longer, it wouldn't
affect anything
else other than, let's say,
the probability that you have
a Down syndrome
child-- how would that
affect the
conversation about now
this sort of
preventative measure
that has nothing
to do with abortion
because the embryo
has not yet formed?
-Well, it's not totally
crazy because we've
seen it in our lifetime.
Neural tube defects in encephaly
where the brain doesn't
form totally, and
problems of spina bifida
have been cut
significantly by putting
folic acid into the diet.
I hate to say this publicly
because it sometimes
makes people who hate
fluoridation nuts,
but it's in your bread.
It's in there.
It was put in, and the
rates have fallen both here
and in countries that had
historically high rates,
like the UK and
Ireland, Scandinavia.
Their rates have fallen.
So the public
health intervention
was deemed so important to
prevent these problems that,
without consent or,
so to speak, almost
surreptitiously, we
put it in the diet
to try and get a solution.
I think that'll
happen and I think
that'll happen for some
things, but it's not going
to happen for a lot of them.
Some of them are just-- there
are massive genetic accidents,
or there's just serious
risks associated
with different types
of mutation affects
that we don't understand or
age-based things and so on.
So yeah, some of
it will get solved
by environmental
prevention, but I
suspect there'll be plenty of
other things-- maybe Downs--
where we're still going
to have this argument.
-[INAUDIBLE]
-Yeah.
I guess maybe I
said this poorly,
but how do you think it
would affect the conversation
from these advocacy groups?
Sort of like what
would their response
be now that it's disconnected
from an abortion?
All these different
groups will not
have the same sort
of rallying cry.
-Yeah.
I think the pro-life
groups would definitely
dissipate in their support for
attention to these matters.
If you take abortion away,
they're not as interested.
-I'm Lauren [INAUDIBLE]
Russell with [INAUDIBLE]
Research and Communications.
I have a different
kind of question,
a little bit along the lines
of the first one, which
is-- I think we are learning
enough about genomics to use it
as a preventative tool,
recognizing that there's
a wide variation of
population response
not only to drugs
but to installed
medical and dental devices.
And that's a topic
I'm working on.
I actually testified at the FDA
hearing on Essure a week ago
Thursday, and it's very clear
that women on the tail ends
of the bell curve don't-- their
immune systems do not handle
nickel, PET, titanium,
and it's extremely harmful
to their health even if
it's installed properly
and doesn't go migrating
around in the body.
I personally got
mercury poisoning
from my dental fillings because
of methylation variance.
How can we push the
field-- because we do not
have the genetic right
to appropriate care.
I don't believe that
concept is even developed.
So how can we get
people like you
in this room to discover
and push and develop
the field of genetic rights
to appropriate care that's
right for us?
-Well, part of the
good news for you
is that the medical complex
is shifting very quickly
to touting
personalized medicine.
Right?
And that's partly genomic.
Personalized medicine
is particularly
loved in the United States where
individualism, autonomy reign,
and no one likes better to hear
that medicine is made for you.
Some of you may have seen ads
on TV for cancer treatments,
and they say we don't give
you just any old care.
We make medicines and a
treatment plan for you.
OK.
That sounds good.
I'm not sure it's true.
So the reason I
don't think it's true
is that, if you go and
look at the cures we have
for different types
of cancers, there's
only three or four of them.
We can tell whether one
is likely to help you
or not in many instances, but we
don't have personalized cures.
It's going to come.
Very popular.
I don't think you're
going to have to push it.
It's just the
science, the amount
of data, the amount of
science, human variability,
gene interactions, epigenetic
interactions on top
of that-- it's just going to
take a while to figure it out,
but I think that day is coming.
We will, in fact, say you're
at high risk of having
an adverse event if
you're exposed to x,
and this is not the
right deodorant for you
because you're going to get
a skin irritation from it
and that sort of thing.
I do think it's coming.
And we want it, as
I said, because we
are so keenly interested in
personalizing our medicine,
but you can't sort of
rush the science past
where the science is.
It's going to take some time,
but it is going to come.
-So you think that-- because
what I'm trying to do
is jumpstart, speed up the
spread from the right medicine
to the right device, which
is not on the radar screen.
-It's just a hard science.
I'm not opposed to
what you're doing.
It's hard.
-Thank you.
-Hi.
-You tell me if I got
to run out of here.
Make this last one?
OK.
-Hi.
I'm Logan Walsh, and I'm an
undergrad at Gordon College.
And you mentioned
Planned Parenthood
and kind of that issue.
And with everything that's
happened in the news recently,
how do you see that kind of
playing out in this argument
and do you think that's going
to sway the issue in any way
and what can we look for in the
next couple of years in regards
to that?
-That's a great question.
It allows me to end the session.
I guess we're going to a
coffee break on a completely
depressing note.
-[CHUCKLING]
-You'll notice, in
the Planned Parenthood
debates about fetal
tissue, that no one
feels bound to debate the
topic in any relationship
to the facts.
-[LAUGHING]
-So we're getting
Carly Fiorina who
says she sees things in
tapes that aren't there
that no one else can find.
We're having all
kinds of arguments
about selling fetal tissue,
changing abortion methods.
But when the nine attorney
generals in different states
have looked, they can't
find anything that indicates
that that practice is going on.
We did see some flip
language going on,
but it didn't show that
anything was happening, so
to speak, there.
So the depressing part
is this-- oftentimes,
when the subjects are women's
health, reproductive health,
abortion, we get more ideology,
I suspect, than we get facts.
We have lots of attitudes
about who's making decisions
and why, about what's
really driving things.
I've been a little disappointed
in the fetal tissue debate
because-- I think
it was in 1992.
I wrote the first articles
about how to ethically procure
a fetal tissue.
I know what the rules are.
There were three basic
ones-- consent the woman,
don't change the
abortion technique,
don't profit, just
get processing fees.
If you really cared about
fetal tissue procurement,
you would just say you were
adhering to these principles.
They've been around for-- I
don't know-- 30 years almost,
but nobody's addressed it.
It's just a hobby horse
for the abortion debate.
End of story.
If I said tomorrow
I've established,
without any dispute, that
fetal tissue is being ethically
procured, people
would still want
to defund Planned Parenthood.
[CHUCKLING]
So to me, that's
the depressing note.
I don't think that
particular issue is really
being debated on the merits.
It's just getting
debated on the politics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you very much.
[MUSIC FADING]